[موسيقى]
من الاول هو نظام الخرطوم والمرسات حيث
نرسل الخرطوم من الجناح وترتبط به الطائره
المستلمه عن طريق المرساد ثم يتم نقل
الوقود النظام الثاني يسمى بومه الذي يقوم
المشغل فيها باستخدام عصا تحكم لايصال
ذراع من الطائره المزوده للوقود الى خزان
الطائره المستلمه هذان هما النظامان
المعياريان في كل القوات الجويه في العالم
[موسيقى]
اليه التزود بالوقود جوا عمليه معقده
لانها تتطلب اقتراب الطائرتين من بعضهما
وهذه الحركه تحدث في المهام العسكريه ولا
نشهدها بين الطائرات المدنيه
[موسيقى]
ولهذا علينا تدريب الاشخاص المعتدين على
التحليق عن قرب من الطائرات الاخرى
والمشغل يجب ان يكون متمرسا في توجيه
العمليه وقادرا على التواصل مع الطائره
الاخرى لربط المرساد
[موسيقى]